we start with this breaking news from
the Turkish Capital anchor there's been
an explosion and gunfire in the Heart of
the City near its Parliament building
the interior Minister says two attackers
were responsible including a suicide
bomber one of them has been killed the
other blew himself up two police
officers have been injured in the attack
let's get the latest from our
correspondent Sim kosu in Istanbul cim
established for us this took place about
an hour and a half ago now establish for
us what happened in the timeline of
events as we know it so far
well s uh in the capital Ankara the area
where the explosion happened is like uh
a diplomatic area or a security area
because uh the capital is a neat City
the Parliament building the ministerial
buildings the embassies they're all uh
one close to each other and uh we know
that the explosion happened very close
to the parliament's building which is
due to open today for its full 2023
session and the interior Minister
building but right after our uh uh
latest uh uh phone connection with you a
half an hour ago a Turkish media has
reported has shown some pictures of the
Light commercial vehicle uh that uh that
was used uh by the perpetrators right in
front of the Gate of the Interior
Ministry building so apparently at this
attack directly targeted the interior
Ministry the message was to the interior
uh Ministry itself because the picture
shows that the car where which was used
by the uh by the perpetrators was harmed
and the barriers of the entrance gate
has also been uh harmed in a way and we
as the interior Minister Ali Alaya
tweeted on his social media there were
two perpetrators one of them was a
suicide bomber H who killed himself and
the other one uh was killed by the H
turkey security Personnel over there and
two Turkish policemen have been uh
slightly injured according to his
statement and he said that the fight uh
by the Turkish authorities targeting uh
what the government calls terrorist
organizations uh will continue until the
last uh what he calls terrorist member
is eliminated this is the situation in
the area the the police has sealed the
area and the the B scads are in the
field because they're also trying to
understand whether there are some extra
explosives on the side or on the vehicle
that was uh that the perpetrators uh
drove uh right to the entrance of the
Interior Ministry in these kind of
situations the bomb scads try to
eliminate uh all uh suspicious packages
inside the trash boxes around the area
any kind of suspicious uh element that
can be a potential uh explosive and uh
cause some further ex uh further
explosions in the area this is what we
saw actually a couple of years ago when
uh some uh attacks were carried out in
Istanbul's taxim District or sutan Ahmed
District where you where there are many
tourists and uh there there was an
explosive uh there was a suicide bomber
and then another explosive left out uh
in the other side of the area so that
right now uh the bomb squats uh the uh
crime investigation team they are
working very neatly uh to see uh to
check any other potential threats are
left out in the area as the parliament
is opening today and in the afternoon
like uh in uh three three and a half
hours uh Turkish lawmakers are going to
be in the parliament for its first day
and Turkish president is going to be in
the parliament yes real quick before I
bring in other voices into this
conversation is it fair to say at this
stage that Turkish law enforcement is
treating this attack as over I mean I
understand that they're securing the
perimeter checking whether there might
be any explosive devices left but the
attack itself over
yes the attack itself seems to be over
but when it comes to these kinds of
attacks you never know because there
sometimes there are uh a series of
attacks in one area in another area but
in the area where the Ministries are
located where the parliament is located
it seems to be over were because the
interior Minister said there were two uh
perpetrate perpetrators whom he called
two terrorists H and they were both
eliminated and uh he didn't underline
any other suspicion or any other
extension uh of the organiz organization
group but of course it is too early to
Stage all these to all right stinum uh
stand by I want to bring in some other
voices into this conversation uh we're
very for forunate that rasul SAR uh is
with us in the studio we'll also go to
our guest next rasul you've obviously
covered tur extensively having been
formerly uh a tur correspondent for Al
jazer you look at this the degree what
is your degree I suppose of surprise
when you see an attack happening in
Turkey we've seen things like this
before absolutely the the the the the
last largest attack that happened in in
Ankara was in 2015 conducted by isil and
tens of people have been killed by that
attack in Ankara terminal so it was
quite a tra tragic event and right after
that we have seen that particularly the
the the the the the Metropol cities in
Turkey in their cities the the security
measures have been quite tightened they
have increased the number of the the the
police officers and also the other
measures have been taken so since then
we haven't seen such a dramatic attack
and this is now happening right in front
of the Interior Ministry which has
hundreds of thousands of its members
that are armed so in that sense it's
quite dramatic however uh what we can
see here now is that the the the attack
has been conducted by two uh
perpetrators but as of now according to
the ministry of interior it has been
brought under the control but one of the
the issue here is is is that so who and
why these are now the speculations
because according to the statement
that's coming from the ministry of
interior is just like two terrorists try
to attack the ministry and one of them
have been killed and the other one
detonated himself or
herself and apparently according to the
statement and the pictures that you're
receiving uh an
arpm uh rocket launcher which is a
russian-made rocket launcher and is
widely used by the pkk or ypg
particularly in Syria so and also as one
of the per perpetrators have has
detonated himself when you look at the
equipments that they have used the way
that they conducted this attack it shows
that now the ministry of interior is
seeing the pkk the most likely
perpetrator here however seeing that
doesn't mean that it's officially that
they're accusing that so this is just
you're trying to read the circumstances
there and trying to to to to to to see
to to to understand to read the
situation the way it was conduct be very
clear and and to sort of pull back the
curtain um for our viewers this is
exactly what all the analysts not to
mention law enforcement in Turkey are
going to be doing right now they they
look at facts on the ground and they see
what they can how they can start to
interpret them and what questions those
raise let's bring in omazic you're a
foreign policy and security analyst
thank you so much sir for uh joining us
you were in you are in Anora and heard
the explosions from what I'm being told
let's just first go there what did you
hear what did you perhaps
see so I did not see anything but I
heard some kind of voice was closer
exposion I'm a bit far to the area of
attack but I this a w I usually use and
I know the area well and knowing it
usually if you have to go to center of
Ankara where all the shopping malls are
where the which is actually the business
place of Ankara Kai you have to drive
along next to the interior Minister then
you have the Turkish Parliament then the
Turkish education Ministry and then the
shopping mall starts and just behind the
interior minister is also a complex of
the Turkish Defense Ministry so it is an
area of the Turkish bureaucracy but it's
quite interesting to underline that this
this area has usually traffic at 930
9:00 but they choose to attack on a
Sunday in which there are usually no
traffic so if they would have to
conducted attacks yesterday or tomorrow
there would be a much greater likelihood
of Civilian casualties and perhaps I
could be one of them because I use this
road uh almost every day so therefore
this attack for me shows that the inter
there was a specific Target and the
attackers specifically tried to attack
iny without
having an aim to cause as much as
possible civan casualties and most
importantly here as well is that if the
attackers would drive some maters much
longer they could have attacked the
Turkish Parliament and this distinction
of choosing the inter Minister over the
defense and the Turkish Parliament I
think it's also important to uh see who
could be behind it and uh as the for
Isis the Turkish Parliament would be a
much more symbolic U attack side
as from the Isis ideology the Turkish
Parliament is demonstrating that turkey
is quote unquote un Islamic and
therefore they would have preferred the
Turkish Parliament to attack but from
the perspective of the pkk the Turkish
Ander Minister would be a much more
logical attack side so Omar I'm I'm uh
listening to what you're saying
listening to what rasul was saying just
now and rasul if you have any questions
for om by all means jump in um we are
looking at an attack that apparently did
not attempt to
maximize civilian casualties we're also
looking at an attack that took place in
one of the most heavily guarded and
secured areas in the entire
country I mean to put it bluntly two men
with a rocket launcher in the middle in
front of the Interior Ministry that was
never going to get very far that's what
I'm reading from what both of you are
saying omed what do you read into
that so I think the goal of the
attackers was clear and they failed so
the goal was to launch Ro attack and
there is a font at the open gate there
usually some Turkish police who secured
the area and after causing some
confusion and destruction and perhaps
killing some Turkish police officers at
the border gate the second attacker was
going to blow himself or herself up in
the entrance of the compound and then
the symbolism would be that the T CH
Minister would attack at its entrance so
they did not have to go to to enter the
compound into it Center or something
like that this was a specific attack of
a suicide mission of two terrorists and
so far we don't know anything about the
identities of the attackers but if one
the suicide attacker was a woman this
would very strongly underlined that it's
very likely the pkk and in contrast to
is you're saying if the attacker were a
woman but that's not the case right so
we can you're saying that would be one
that would be well isn't the interior
Ministry reporting that the two
attackers were men did I did I get that
wrong not yet we do not know their
gender yet okay oh okay hold on let me
let me double check that then um rasul
denm we don't know absolutely we don't
know if they were men or women what we
know the ministry of interior saying
that two perpetrators so not specifying
whether it's women or male we do not
know that okay s maybe I jumped to
conclusions earlier the interior
Ministry did not give us that
information
correct no actually this is all about
the Turkish uh grammar and the English
grammar we don't have gender definition
when we're mentioning about uh him or
her he just said two terrorists uh two
terrorists he didn't uh specify the
gender and he didn't specify any
possible links to any possible thank you
that so that is invaluable Insight omed
pick up on the point that you were
making then man woman that could be
already something that you know gives us
some pretty significant
Clues yes because in contrast to Isis
pkk's distorted ideology believes in
gender equality in terrorist attacks and
therefore preferably use women and we
know from the past in Turkey in Syria
and in Iraq that the PK usually prefers
to use wom as a form of wom Liberation
it's a distorted ideology unfortunately
but Isis has not use uh on the V areas
except to some few exemptions woman in
the suicide attack yeah and just
recently particularly in the last couple
of weeks we have seen that a huge
increase in the operations that are
conducted by the Turkish Security Forces
Army uh the Turkish intelligence and the
ministry of interior across the country
in Syria and in Iraq particularly going
after the pkk members or those who they
claim they are linked to so and in the
last couple of weeks you will wake up in
the morning and SE an official statement
from the ministry of interior saying
that thousands of the police officers
last night were involved in an operation
against such a group and hundreds of
them have been arrested this could be
the armed dealers the the drug dealers
or the pkk members even the isil members
as well so the dramatic increase of the
operations conducted by the police is
also showing us that probably one of
these actors could have a kind of
discontent regarding that and that could
be a kind of Act of retaliation as well
so here as the and that would TI in with
the specific Target because they
targeted now we've established that they
targeted of all the government buildings
that were there and diplomatic uh
facilities that are in that area they
targeted the interior Ministry getting
in front of the the headquarter of the
Turkish military definitely will be much
more difficult or getting in front of
the Turkish the the headquarter of the
Turkish intelligence will be almost
impossible so I think among these three
because these three Ministries and the
the directories are the ones that are
coordinating these operations right so
among them the easiest Target probably
was the minister of interior and that's
why they have picked that up and it
seems that this is a suicide attack
because simply one of the attackers
right after doing giving as much as harm
then he detonated to blow himself or
herself up so that's why probably it was
a kind of organized um attack that has
been ordered by someone or the groups
that are having a discontent
particularly regarding the the recent um
the the recent uh operations that have
been conducted by the security forces
and it was not only across turkey but
also in Syria and in Iraq as well and we
have seen that several senior members of
ypg and the pkk particularly recently
have been killed by the Drone attacks in
a coordination between the these three
Ministries s coo you've had to report on
the attacks on attacks not like this one
but on attacks in Turkey a before and on
the aftermath of the attacks what is the
investigation going to look like I mean
in the hours after an attack what does
law enforcement have to do and what do
they look
at well s definitely all security uh
units of the government of the state is
working uh hard
right now first they sealed the area and
the bom squads were in place H they are
trying to see whether there are any
other explosive devices hidden under the
car or any closed by places that's why
we are seeing on reports that the bomb
squads are working and they are trying
to detonate any kind of bags or packs
inside trash cans uh in the area close
by that has been sealed by the security
uh forces right now as we have mentioned
earlier today is the first uh day of uh
the parliament's uh winter session fall
session and president Ardon is scheduled
to deliver an opening speech in the
parliament around 2 pm local which is
nearly uh 3 hours uh from now on and the
lawmakers have already began getting
inside the Parliament building but
apparently the latest pictures that show
that uh Light commercial vehicle used by
uh the trators being par parked right in
front of the Gate of the Interior
Ministry so there's a specific message
but what Omar has underlined is very
valuable uh during the weekdays as we
also have an office in the capital
ankora and we always cover sure uh
all political events in that area is
very crowded and everyone in Ankara
especially if you're working in the H
City Center you cross by that area and
there's a huge population using public
transportation they private cars that's
why this is very interesting that they
have chosen uh this the weekend uh
Sunday for this attack is it because
they avoided uh the any collateral
damage or is it
because
first but when looking back to the
attacks carried out by other uh armed
groups like isil they usually prefer
collateral damage and um of course in
these kinds of incidents mostly uh the
Security Experts who speak on uh media
they usually refer to the outd Kurdistan
Workers Party H and also there's a
leftist group called uh Dash DH a KPC
this is also another suspected group in
these kinds of incidents we don't have
any spe specifics about uh the situation
but according to Interior ministers it's
tweets and his explanations things seem
to be contained but investigation is
slightly underway and now there is a
broadcast ban for Turkish media about
the
incident okay that's also interesting
context look I want to thank all of you
this is what we know right now and
thanks for the information you gave us
the context you gave us notably and and
we're going to just wrap this up with
this
thought several of you in fact you've
all emphasized that this attack appears
to have taken place in a way that
minimize civilian casualties okay that's
something we're going to be looking into
uh as we bring you back on the shows in
the coming hours thank you cin kosu in
Istanbul Omar us keljik thank you very
much and on a personal note we're
obviously very happy and we we that
you're safe and we hope for everybody's
continued safety in anchora rul SAR
thank you for joining us on set and for
your
expertise